c'est un type qui est
qui dans un bar et puis il arrive au bar
comme ça et puis voit une fille
aussi jolie il a regardé il fait
tu baises
l afje elle est folle de rage et en plus
elle fait partie de mitu enfin bon prend
le même car elle fracasse ac 2 contre le
bas le mec tombe par terre elle prend le
truc du bar le cas sur le dos elle finit
à coups de lattes dans la gueule lui
peine trois dents mais qu'il est on sent
comme ça si grâce à
la regarde
je suppose que tu fais
là j'ai
[Applaudissements]
fini c'est fini j'ai une arme parce
qu'après j'ai remarqué ouais quand je
fais ça après j'en ai pour dix ans ça
repasse sur les réseaux sociaux et mais
qui me dit le perroquet mais pendant dix
ans dans un accident il me fait monsieur
racontez moi le père en fils je joue là
bas
c'est 2 deux homosexuels qui ont fait
naufrage
et alors et ceux ci se sont rués sur une
île déserte abandonné de tous tes leur
demande une émission fait pipi
ils sont beaux et je la fais un pays
sont va assez féminin et alors ils ont
fait sur la petite île où ils sont
naufragés ça fait même un petit jardin
une petite maison ils ont fait le coin
avec les les hamacs comme ça ils ont
tous fabriqués tous vraiment c'est
l'heure si l'on fait un petit coin d'un
mot magnifique et au bout de un mois un
mois et demi qui sont en norvégien des
deux qui dit moi
bientôt auxquelles on n'a pas pensé
et le sexe comment on fait
petit fille tu as raison tu as raison
comment va faire c'est d'allemagne a pas
pensé le petit génie des
jets d'eau d'in devis n'est plus beau
site à la réponse
c'est une fois qui fait l'homme
autrement dit dans le texte c'est acquis
continent
bah oui on commenté
et si c'est si tu trouves pas eh ben
c'est moi qui fait l'homme jouait super
super tu
vas là la devinette
il faut que tu ton quel est l'animal tu
es tout gris qu'elle est grand ouvert
certes de défense et une trompe pas qui
fait c'est dur
c'est dur jamais dû me trouve
grand
gagnant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand je suis sur les routes en tournée
tout ça avec mon équipe on a 300
kilomètres à faire que je suis en forme
299 km je raconte une histoire
du rip leur bon je raconte
géraldine et jardinent une petite vous
allez
c'est un cauchemar michel est ce que tu
dois faire une dernière après avoir
annoncé hier une dernière sur ma vie
fais moi celle de l'ours lmmc le
tonnerre avec ton appelant mes bras
pendant cinq jours à venir cueillir un
sac de gérard inserv l'aveuglent à merci
merci
vous
l'avez compris longa non j'ai pas de nom
non pas maintenant je suis incapable je
suis de rythme je devrais être dans mon
livre
[Rires]
ok et puis après je dois la première du
film de lelouch parce que je veux
soutenir aussi est on y est je vais y
aller demain je vais voir demain il sera
avec nous d'ailleurs un creux de lelouch
et par est formidable je le bois de bon
c'est un aveugle et sur une plage et
pays gonfle un truc qui fait
alors et au bout de vos moyens policiers
qui arrive c'est monsieur fait ouais
c'est ya un problème je sais quoi c'est
vous gonflez ouais je m'en fous
mais vous gonflez une poupée gonflable
ça gêne les gens auto il fait pas je
cours tous les bons cela c'est oui
monsieur
ça fait un mois que je couche avec bon
audio
[Applaudissements]
c'est
juste après
celle des vins quand ils ont pris toute
la collection envers away a juste à la
après c'est vrai je te le film la
facture
le rappelle plus il m'a fatigué je
savais qu'en allant de venir ici la
limite le prêt à temps franchement c'est
oui mais bon
moi mais après les jeunes qui voient ça
ils vont venir
[Rires]
c'est c'est beau c'est maintien tipi
rentre dans un magasin de vêtements de
tissus aux sentiers enfin à l'époque où
dans le chantier mais encore des gens de
chez moi
non mais maintenant c'est vrai ça change
et ça a bougé et
dit bonjour monsieur le tuf et bonjour
savoir fouet il fait je voudrais du
tissu rouge vous avez ça il fait
tout bien il revient avec un tissu vert
dit vous avez vu ce vers quoi il est
beau vous avez cité
il pousse site du gazon c'est une
merveille ça veut dire on a remis de
s'allonger dessus on a envie de jouer au
golf on est revenu à une piscine on l'a
fait à côté parce qu'ils les verts il ya
plus beaux que ceux vers une merveille
tu fais je suis très beau mais moi ce
que je veux c'est sûr
qu'à tissu bleu
c'est la méditerranée ont replongé
dedans mais j'aime pas ça tu battu
magentis eut demandé beau ya des
dauphins et les crevettes
regarde le yacht regarde bien tu vas
voir le yacht
conz à m'énerver c'est pas ben le nez
univers je veux c'est rouge vous avez
compris calmez-vous
rouge je reviens
inutile de vous dire que
si vous m'aimez revel avait dû régler
[Rires]
le problème de ces histoires c'est que
je les connais par coeur et moi je ris
parce que ce que j'aime c'est le
mécanisme et que tu fais ça le diplomate
issu prince de galles
c'est quoi la reine d'angleterre je vais
des moines de téléphone me dit vendée
c'est pour mon fils
de louis précise comme si son compte ou
sur
des raisonnements bah oui ça doit être
avait
il ya plus beau que ce prince de galles
c'est une merveille ces merveilles ils
vont se battre l'angleterre quand ils
vont le voir et où l'autre il est fou de
rage fou de rage il prend le type mime
fracassa ufc rouge et andy nous le
diction
c'est rouge que je veux te compris
connard c'est pourquoi je
sais j'ai pas
[Applaudissements]